ce que j'ai cette faire parce que il y a
tout de même une préparation personnelle
c'est d'être personnellement devenu
meurt allez alors ils ont été à nous
[Musique]
en principe moi quand je sors j'ai rien
de prévu je prends mon bahut
je pars à partir du moment où je puisse
sortir du garage
je cherche
en principe surtout le matin aux heures
où je commence je n'ai pas besoin de
station je trouve un client et ça
commence comme ça bon je pars d'un point
de vue c'est que quand le client sort de
chez lui il sort pas avec l'idée d'aller
à une station il sort avec l'idée de
trouver un taxi alors dès qu'il a mis le
pied sur le trottoir devant le 14 de la
rue machin il cherche comprenez il
cherche il y a pas d'histoire alors ce
qu'il faut c'est que je le rends compte
il faut qu'on se provoque il faut bon
alors moi je travaille comme ça c'est ce
qui vous plaît le PLUS alors moi je vais
vous dire je m'en fous
moi j'ai 10 heures de travail à faire
pendant 10 heures
je suis libre je suis là pour gagner ma
vie il faut que le compteur tourne comme
il tourne en ce moment bon
c'est un métier qui peut être très drôle
qui peut être unique mais alors il faut
le vouloir alors il y a deux façons de
le prendre
il y en a un qui est les emmerdeurs de
clients les
méchants
de circulation c'est
bon si on le prend comme ça pratiquement
il y a pas un client qui peut vous
satisfaire parce qu'il y a pas de bonne
course moi le matin
ce que j'ai cette faire parce qu'il y a
tout de même une préparation personnelle
c'est d'être personnellement devenir
allez alors ils ont été à nous
alors moi le matin c'est ma première
journée de taxi de la vie je sais rien
du métier j'ai tout à apprendre un
client je sais parce que c'est
et puis voilà alors
le client un petit peu on peut dire fait
le chauffeur bon au départ enfin le
client peut faire le chauffeur je veux
dire que s'il monte dans cette voiture
en claquant la portière puis en me
disant en me jetant l'adresse comme un
os j'ai pas quoi moi
la fenêtre rendez pas avec le ventifère
enfin bon je peux évidemment le prendre
très mal pour son billet de 1000 francs
il m'a pas acheté moi et ma bagnole
enfin
il y a d'abord un truc c'est que quel
que soit
la condition du client son état son
caractère au moment présent où il arrive
et bien presque tous n'est-ce pas Braine
le temps en arrivant enfin s'ils
arrivent de face ils testent le
chauffeur d'un regard
il faut dire le mot il faut aimer son
client
[Musique]
il y a les clients pressés
il y a les clients gentils
il y a les clients anonymes
le client vient du tout alors le client
pressé vous le voyez dès qu'il arrive il
arrive au courant il arrive affoler
[Musique]
il vous voit vous êtes devant lui il
continue de vous chercher
bon enfin ça y est vous êtes là alors il
se précipite là dedans il claque la
portière
rien vous dire il faudrait déjà qu'il
soit arrivé il y a enfin bon ce seul
villa on sait quand on le voit arriver
que il va falloir
trouver le chemin où il y a personne il
va falloir le miracle ça s'il y a pas de
miracle pour celui-là il va falloir
trouver autre chose pour le consoler
parce que sinon il va être malheureux
bon et puis alors il y a le client
tranquille qui prend son taxi tous les
matins à 8h moins le quart
qui commence à 9h15 9h30 ou 10h c'est
sans importance
c'est pas le matin l'après-midi alors à
partir de 3h il y a il y a les magasins
il y a aussi les objets perdus histoire
on va trois fois la semaine aux objets
perdus toujours avec des dames qui
perdent des choses dans les taxis
en principe la maraude c'est interdit
n'est-ce pas c'est à dire que
du reste il faudrait s'entendre parce
que un client vous elle au bord du
trottoir taxi bon vous n'avez pas le
droit de ne pas vous arrêter mais vous
n'avez pas le droit non plus de vous
arrêter si ça gêne la circulation or
vous avez le devoir de rouler au rythme
de la circulation voyez-vous or un
client ça se cherche pas à 77 à l'heure
voyez-vous alors Autriche
Autriche on roule lentement au bord du
trottoir on essaie de gêner le moins
possible on essaie d'être le
de respecter le plus possible et les
choses mais en principe les
l'état d'esprit contre nous demeure
n'est-ce pas un taxi c'est un gars qui
en maraude en mer tout le monde et une
fois chargé vous passerez dessus c'est
un métier enfin c'est un refuge vous ne
trouverez pas un chauffeur de taxi qui
est eu envie de faire le chauffeur de
taxi il s'agit seulement de savoir
conduire une voiture bon bah ça tout le
monde le fait plus ou moins heureusement
enfin tout le monde le sait il s'agit
d'apprendre
il s'agit d'apprendre les rues de Paris
alors pour ça il y a des écoles vous
êtes interrogés sur les rues de Paris où
elle commence où elle finit sur les
itinéraires qui sont définies
par la Préfecture de Police n'est-ce pas
une fois pour toutes vous êtes interrogé
à cet examen sur les monuments de Paris
n'est-ce pas enfin les principaux
monuments et puis
sur toute la réglementation intérieure
du taxi les vitres doivent être au goût
du client fermé ouverte à demi enfin
selon ce que le client souhaite le
client a le droit d'exiger un itinéraire
ce n'est pas à vous de dessiner c'est à
Lui chauffeur de taxi c'est un outil
aussi bien que la voiture qui va
transporter une cliente
pour lui vous n'êtes pas là n'est-ce pas
il y a la preuve de toutes les
conversations même intimes qui se qui se
passe dans cette voiture entre couple
n'est-ce pas et qui et qui ne se
raconterait pas je sais pas moi dans un
ascenseur ou comprenez donc la preuve
est que on ne fait pas attention au
chauffeur
alors ça ça vous donne le moyen
d'écouter ça vous pouvez écouter ce qui
se passe les gens ne se gênent pas pour
vous à aucun moment ils sont ce qu'ils
ont envie d'être ce qu'ils sont
il y en a qui sont
qui s'installent dans la voiture et qui
sont chez elles mais c'est
principalement les dames ça voyez-vous
il y en a eu du foie je la voyais
fricoter derrière je savais pas trop
quoi être très moussait enfin pas
attention enfin pas trop parce que quand
même faire attention à ce qui se passe
devant
pas au bout d'un moment ça me donne un
petit paquet
voulez-vous jeter ça parce que oui
[Musique]
j'ai profité d'être là pour en change et
ben oui voilà alors pourquoi pas
heureusement ça c'est la halle du Midi
on fait bien le plein de la voiture
c'est fatigant il faut se ménager une
dépense
enfin physique nerveuse exemple le soir
après la journée on est on a envie de
marcher on a envie de d'aller pour sa
vieille mère chercher du charbon à la
cave on a on a envie de faire quelque
chose il y a une nuance entre les
astuces entre le matin et l'après-midi
n'est-ce pas parce que le matin
il ne faut pas prendre les itinéraires
en principe les itinéraires à petite rue
parce que alors à tous les coups c'est
le livreur c'est la cita c'est etc donc
plutôt les grandes voix
qui roule pas très bien mais qui sont
plus surveillés par la police voyez-vous
alors il y a pas d'abus possible celui
qui qui ne prend pas de taxi couramment
il en prend le moins possible pour ces
raisons mais il en prend le moins
possible alors quand il en prend un
encore une fois c'est la fête et puis
alors on lui a tellement dit il entend
tellement dire attention au taxi en les
taxis vous prenez des taxis alors ça
vous comprenez cet épouvantable alors il
surveille tout un sujet là je me
souviens une fois
là j'ai cru vraiment que le pauvre type
c'était la première fois qu'il prenait
un taxi je baisse le compteur Guy quoi
il y a des gens un franc cinquante
c'était à l'ancien prix mais monsieur
alors il regardait partout il voulait un
témoin il voulait quelque chose qu'il
rassure qu'il renseigne qui non monsieur
mais oui enfin on part en France c'est
la prise en charge depuis que gentiment
parce qu'il n'y a pas besoin de
ah bon enfin alors c'était déjà gâché
déjà s'il avait su on est en grand taxi
alors au bout d'un moment
mais
ça fait déjà 70 mais oui mais
mais ça devrait être un 60
ça va par 20 centimes alors évidemment
il m'énervait parce que quand même
c'est pas on peut débuter mais je pense
à ce point-là quand je dis vous allez
assister à cette chose absolument
scandaleuse c'est que plus on ira vous
allez voir ce phénomène plus ça va
s'aggraver
j'ai toujours ému quand je croise un
agent qui me fait un sourire ça fait
plaisir
je crois que je fais 10 heures de
travail et qu'en principe je commence à
6h du matin j'assiste par conséquent au
lever de Paris au réveil de Paris
de ces différents réveils parce que
évidemment à Belleville à cette heure
tout le monde est élevé enfin en
principe à l'Opéra ça commence à ouvrir
les yeux devant moi le quart
qu'on travaille dans un bureau qu'on va
à l'usine enfin bon mais moi
pendant 10 ans de 6 heures à 9h
j'assiste à ces différents réveils moi
je suis déjà là
je suis déjà en train de regarder
[Musique]